[Musique]
le moment est solennel
la victoire est d'autant plus savoureuse
pour joe biden que la bataille a été
difficile une longue marche vers le
podium avec la vice-présidente kamala
harris qu'on avait pas vu depuis
longtemps
leur relation serait tendu mais peu
importe ce qui se dit dans les coulisses
aujourd'hui est une journée de
célébration le projet de loi sur
l'infrastructure va enfin devenir loin
[Applaudissements]
cette loi dit le président pour la
première fois en 20 ans l'infrastructure
américaine va se développer plus
rapidement que celles en chine on aura
les plus belles routes ponts aéroports
d'ici la prochaine décennie et
l'administration va aider n'aura mis le
paquet 1200 milliards de dollars qui
comprend 100 milliards pour l'accès à
l'internet 111 milliards pour l'accès à
l'eau potable après la contamination
pour du réseau d'eau potable de la ville
de flint
bref on ne lésine pas sur les coûts
d'infrastructure du pays a besoin de
sérieuse rénovation
face à des routes des ponts des aqueducs
en décrépitude
tous les états rouge et bleu se sont
ralliés dit il joe biden a gagné son
pari d'être un rassembleur
c'est crucial pour des gens que moi dit
elle car ça va créer des millions
d'emplois
puis le moment tant attendu
démocrates et républicains célèbre
ensemble un projet de loi qui a failli
être rejeté
si ce n'était de l'appui de 13
républicains à la chambre des
représentants the biggest loser ceci
devrait être le début d'efforts
renouvelés pour le bien du pays dit il
mais ceux qui ont voté en faveur d'un
projet sur l'infrastructure ont subi
l'ire de dornach chambre certains ont
même reçu des menaces de mort anonymes
il reste maintenant pour
l'administration byden le projet de loi
sur les réformes sociales et
l'environnement qui divise vraiment les
deux partis
le congrès doit faire passer ce projet
de loi rappelle comment la rs avec cette
loi sur l'infrastructure joe biden
espère remonter sa cote de popularité
qui est en baisse le dernier sondage
indique que plus de 60% des américains
estiment qu'il n'a pas accompli grand
chose toujours est il que le président
s'entretient ce soir avec son homologue
chinois il sera question entre autres
d'économie de technologie car la chine
est toujours dans la mire des états unis
ici assez bonne longueur 10 radio canada
washington